laure de la raudière mais merci monsieur
le président mes chers collègues je
souhaite à mon tour salué la mémoire de
notre collègue sophie dessus
c'était une femme de conviction engagé
toujours positive très gai apprécié
surtout c'est ben c'était une belle
figure des femmes députées au nom du
groupe l'est républicain je présente nos
sincères condoléances à sa famille et à
ses proches
monsieur le premier ministre les
français fulmine devant le cynisme
politique de votre gouvernement sacrifie
les réformes nécessaires de la france
sur l'autel du parti socialiste de votre
parti chaque jour j'entends leur
écoeurement
il vous reproche non pas de ne rien
faire mais surtout de tout faire pour
que rien ne change
vous agissez comme un premier secrétaire
adjoint du parti socialiste votre
dérobade sur le projet de loi et comrie
monde comment vous courber l'échiné
devant madame aubry est devant les
syndicats qui trop souvent ne
représentent qu'eux mêmes
pendant ce temps les entreprises et les
français récit d'airé de l'énergie que
vous mettez à leur mentir vous ne cessé
d'évoquer les 40 milliards d'euros de
baisses de charges d'efforts fiscaux
consacré aux entreprises mais jamais
vous n'osez dire que le niveau de
prélèvements sur les entreprises n'est
toujours pas revenu à celui de 2012
voilà le résultat de votre politis karl
des six premiers mois de 2012
où sont vos réformes pour les
entreprises rien sur la transformation
profonde de notre économie
rien sur la digitalisation des
entreprises rien sur l'export
rien sur l'orientation de la commande
publique pour les pme
rien sur la stabilité de la fiscalité
rien rien cela ne peut plus durer
monsieur le premier ministre quand allez
vous enfin trouvé le courage qui
visiblement vous manque pour demander un
autre ministre de l'économie de faire
les réformes qui s'imposent
lui qui passe des journées à les
présenter à la presse et dans les médias
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls ce président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
merci madame laure de la raudière pour
les mots à l'égard de sophie dessus
demain il y aura ses obsèques en
présence du président de la république
qui perd une amie chers camarades chers
présence du président de l'assemblée
nationale et nous aurons ici même
l'occasion vous le rappeliez monsieur le
président de lui rendre hommage
en effet elle va nous manquer par sa
ténacité son sourire sa bonne humeur et
son attachement à la cause madame laure
de la raudière je n'ai pas envie de
polémiquer
votre question est caricatural
outrancière le gouvernement c'est votre
droit de le critiquer de proposer une
alternative à ce que nous faisons il est
vrai déjà eu l'occasion de le souligner
combien la fiscalité en effet pesait
depuis plusieurs années sur les ménages
comme sur les entreprises le choix qui a
été fait avec le 6e puis à partir de
2014 avec le pacte de responsabilité et
de solidarité c'est de baisser oui le
coût du travail et la fiscalité sur les
entreprises
mais ce pacte de responsabilité et de
solidarité a été soutenue reste soutenue
à la fois par les organisations
patronales et les syndicats réformistes
et c'est sur ces bases là que nous avons
entamé avec myriam el khomri avec
emmanuel macron toute une série de
discussions
deux rendez vous avec les partenaires
sociaux en bilatérales au cours de cette
semaine et lundi prochains
collectivement dans le cadre de ces
quinze jours que nous sommes donnés pour
mieux expliquer le texte de loi porté
par la ministre du travail pour corriger
ce qui doit l'être pour modifier avec à
chaque fois la même idée de l'est plus
de liberté plus de souplesse plus de
visibilité plus de flexibilité aux
entreprises et en même temps assurer des
protections et des droits nouveaux
à travers le compte personnel d'activité
pour les salariés il y à un débat dans
le pays sur le code du travail
c'est une bonne chose parce que chacun
peut s'apercevoir là où il ya des droits
qu'il faut protéger des changements et
des améliorations qu'il faut porter est
plutôt madame la députée plutôt que
d'être dans la critique outrancière
caricatural parce que au fond ce qui ne
marche plus c'est ça de quelques côté
que ça soit de l'hémicycle c'est se
renvoyer en permanence la responsabilité
ses portes et des caricatures sur les
uns et les autres et je pense que c'est
de cela dont les français ne veulent
plus là donc plutôt que d'être dans
cette caricature
attendez que le texte vienne devant
l'assemblée nationale
d'abord devant la commission des
affaires sociales
début avril et ensuite ici dans cet
hémicycle fin avril et début mai pour
pouvoir discuter faire des propositions
pour améliorer la compétitivité de notre
économie de nos entreprises dans un
monde ouvert avec la révolution du
numérique et pour améliorer la situation
les salariés car au fond il n'y a qu'une
seule chose qui nous intéresse avec la
ministre du travail et ministre de
l'économie dans cette affaire une seule
chose c'est bien sûr protéger les
salariés qui aujourd'hui ont un emploi
mais s'est fait en sorte que ceux qui
depuis les années ces centaines de
milliers ces millions de chômeurs
souvent jeunes souvent pour beaucoup qui
connaissent le chômage depuis longtemps
peut qualifier puissent avoir accès au
marché du travail et qu'on puisse ainsi
levé ses barrières du travail
c'est cela que nous sommes en train de
faire est plutôt que d'être dans la
caricature
venez avec vos propositions et c'est
comme cela que nous serons vous et moi
utile à la france et à l'intérêt général
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la pole est à madame bernadette laclais